we do have one more thing today we're
announcing Apple music I'm drew Coolidge
and I'm here to tell you about the newly
announced Apple music this is hashtag
news Apple came out guns-a-blazing
they're trying to take down the
competition with a vengeance Apple music
will feature radio stations that will
allow subscribers to skip as many songs
as they want and will be curated by
human djs not algorithms DJ's will
include Zane Lowe ebro darden julieta
naega DJ flash I made up maybe all of
those the service will be nine
ninety-nine a month but only 14 99 for
up to six people Spotify on the other
hand has a same monthly price for only
two people what there is no free tier
but it will have a free three month
trial Drake himself came on stage to
show off Connect connect as an artist
blog posting service music artists
signed and unsigned big and small can
share their stuff like remixes lyrics
new songs etc it also includes exclusive
interviews behind-the-scenes videos and
blog entries from your favorite artists
this is apple's attempt to simplify the
way we connect with artists centralizing
information that we see on tumblr
twitter facebook etc oh this is very
similar to a feature that title has been
promoting too we get it Apple you're
starting a fight last year apple
acquired dr. dre's beats for 3 billion
dollars now they're relaunching iTunes
radio leading with beats 1 radio which
would be a live worldwide 24-7 radio
station for the most exciting music and
the people that love it in all corners
the globe Siri can now be your own
personal robot DJ you can give her
commands like lay the top R&B songs or
play the top song in June of 1984 and
she'll do it and if you don't know what
that song from whiplashes you can just
say Siri play that song from whiplash
and she'll do that Siri not quite my
tempo hit like if you're excited for all
the new Apple music features I want to
start a turf war in the comment section
if you're all about Apple music let us
know if you think one of the other
players has the edge over apple music do
that too and as always subscribe to new
media rock stars for all the latest
apple news I'm drew Coolidge and I hope
that Apple music doesn't cut into the
profits from the player I'm trying to
develop it's called drew sick and it
plays all the music you don't want to
hear walk fun gotten up stop you're
gonna hate
ah